wow let's get serious class
is in session okay actor comedian dion
cole is giving vegas a lesson in coal
ology tomorrow at encore theater and i
caught up with him to
learn more check it out how you doing
headed on tour
oh it's been great man just uh
traveling around and preparing to uh
shoot my fourth special i started
shooting
uh well i shoot it september 10th in
brooklyn new york so
just been
performing and making sure it's nice and
tight before i go shoot it so
uh vegas is definitely one of the last
spots before i go to new york let's go
back a little bit let's talk about
blackish this is such an important show
for the culture
for tv in general just what does the
show mean to you and your career
um it just means you know
um
unity and that's what it's always
represented uh
with what other nationalities as well as
within our own and uh also within uh age
brackets you know and that's what the
show is about it was about bridging the
gap between
old and young and so um and doing it in
a you know in a hilarious way and you
said bridging gaps it's it's taught
everyone so much um now i guess i could
call you professor
professor cole as you're teaching
everybody coalology on your tour
um did your blackish character or your
experience with blackish have anything
to do with with your inspiration for
callology
no no no so a long time ago i had a um a
special on comedy center and it was
called
cold blooded seminar and so that's what
i was i used and this was before
blackish and i used to always have this
thing where i do my shows and
like um kind of like it was almost like
a seminar that's how people used to
always tell me when they left the shows
like man where's the next seminar so
that's why i named it that and so
cholology was just kind of a spin off of
the uh
seminar thing that i used to do so yeah
and basically it's just my
life logic towards you know things
that's going on in the world you know
can you give us a little lesson real
quick adam and eve the very first people
on the planet earth
uh they have belly buttons and why
who can who cut their umbilical cords
i be thinking about stuff people don't
know about people ain't even thinking
about like for example
why isn't there any b batteries
this is the thing man my audience is a
different audience it's black people who
think just smart intelligent
beautiful black people coming out having
a good time always beautiful women
always successful
successful nice looking man at my shows
all around the country so yeah it's
gonna be a good time now do you have any
uh plans outside of your show here in
vegas what do you like to do when you
come here to hang out man i'm gonna go
check out a couple things uh i love
going every time i come now let's go
check out mike jackson
oh yeah i'm gonna go check out some
other shows and
yeah you know just you know hang out go
check out last year there anything you
can you can give to you know up and
coming comedians or in actors or people
who are you know aspiring some advice um
just give us you and don't give us don't
don't just give us comedy
we can get comedy anywhere
go out there and be who you are
and get money for it
whoa
all right well that my friends was a
lesson in cologne
mike drive mike drive
all right dion cole is performing at
encore theater tomorrow night do not
miss him he was hilarious that was a
great interview yeah that was fun all
right